The Joe Rogan experience.
Silly.
Yeah.
I have a windows laptop and I have an apple laptop.
Oh you do?
Yeah.
Jeez.
I both really,
yeah.
You know why?
Cause windows has more options and when you have more options you get better
configurations.
You get better keyboards.
Right.
Like A,
I have a Lenovo thinkpad dude.
They're the shit.
Yeah,
it's way better to write on like the tactile feedback and the travel distance
and the keys is so much longer.
Right.
You just know where you're typing it.
For me as a writer,
when I'm writing like I'm writing stand up or something like that,
it requires less thinking cause my fingers just find the keys easier.
I mean like 10% plus easier.
It's a big deal.
And I bought an older apple laptop too.
I bought a 2015 a refurbished one cause their keyboards were superior.
Yes.
The new ones are so low profile type of anything.
The shittiest fucking keyboard of any computer that you could buy today is a new
Mac book pro and they got busted for that because now because their keywords
associated,
if we take them back now,
they didn't recalls in the keyboard.
While they do have a new patent that they put out for a variable height
keyboard,
where the key travel will vary in the key resistance will.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
This is a new patent that they filed for.
It doesn't necessarily mean they even have the technology for it.
That sounds expensive.
I don't know why.
If it's something that you could press a button that just raises the keys up,
that would be like a solution.
Because if you think about the flatness of the key,
the idea is they want to keep a low profile to this laptop,
right?
Make it thin and sexy,
which is like fucking whatever the,
I don't have the thing pad with me,
but I have the x one carbon.
It's sad.
Those are nice.
This relate to.
Right,
and the battery life is excellent.
Six months,
dude.
It's a fucking great laptop.
Right?
So Apple's just,
they're just only apple.
And the problem with that one company only selling laptops is you just don't
have enough variety.
There's not enough people that are offering challenges to it.
They don't have any challenges.
In fact,
their biggest challenge is the walkway mate book.
Huawei basically stole their,
their idea and but made it way better.
They made they,
oh,
I see what you guys are doing.
You guys are fucking up.
I'm going to do that same way.
If we're going to make it with better keys,
right?
We're going to have no bezels on the side of the screen and you know everyone's
concerned about security.
Well,
we're just going to have the Webcam pop up as a key.
Have you seen that?
No,
I haven't.
No.
Dope.
That sounds next level shit.
I want to see that while way.
Am I saying that right?
That's it.
Come on Bro.
Oh shoot.
That's dope as fuck.
Look no bezels.
No bezels.
No,
no room for the Webcam and it has great keyboard travel too.
I think it's like 1.5 millimeter key travel,
which is if you're a person who writes all the time,
yeah I need to get my thoughts out.
I'm stupid.
Do you write a lot?
Write a lot.
Stand up.
And I just write things and extract,
stand up from them and right.
But when I write I,
I don't need to be fucking with the keys man.
So why do you use your Mac then?
You,
there's all these pros about the,
about the PC.
But why do you cause I like to have both.
I use that when I travel cause I don't write as much when I travel.
But I like to watch movies and show that pops up.
Right.
How about that?
That's the f six gears.
It looks right up.
You know,
son,
I'm pretty wild but that's good because of weird because it's profile.
The biggest thing is like when you're,
you,
you probably have like a Skype meetings or whatever,
Google hangouts.
Uh,
the worst thing in the world is like the camera turning on automatically.
That's a lie right there.
That image is a lie because they can go back up.
That is not what it was.
Yeah,
I know.
That's impossible.
Even the right viewpoint.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
No one's that good looking either.
Yeah.
She's pretty hot.
Yeah,
but it does pop up,
man.
That's in state.
So that's,
that's a thing because it was just like a Mac.
Yep.
It looks just like a Mac,
except it is more key travel.
Right.
More comfortable.
And that upper right hand corner,
that power Bi has also fingerprint reader.
Oh fuck it.
I'm going to buy one right now.
[inaudible] the shit I would,
I would use one.
But you don't have one?
No.
When did I have?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's great to have her do,
I mean this is just,
they're there.
It's all just better options.
The only difference is windows is not as good as macro s but it's not that much
worse.
No,
it's really not.
It's pretty fucking close.
Windows 10 is pretty fucking good.
And see what this round,
what does it run on?
Windows or some two windows.
Windows.
Windows,
windows,
windows 10 yeah,
sure.
It's not android.
No.
That's a good one that day.
Right.
It would have to be one of those Chromebooks.
I was going to run android,
which apparently is very good.
The Chromebook designs are really nice too.
Very nice.
They're super nice and you can get one super cheap.
Right.
And the battery lasts like three months.
Yes.
Forever.
And if you just putting documents,
you put them in your Google docs in the cloud,
you pull it up instantaneous.
I drive.
No,
it's great.
Yeah.
But why ways?
A weird company man.
Like I don't know what I feel about,
I'm buying into all this government propaganda about the Chinese spying on us.
Yeah,
it's definitely spying on you for sure.
Dot.
Huh?
Well Dude,
I've had my credit card stolen,
my number stolen three times this year.
How?
Why?
I don't know if it's ever happened to me.
Yeah,
well I think the more money you have,
the more stuff you get stolen.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe people find out.
It's annoying though.
Like I got a charge,
but I have an app on my phone that shows me to charge and it was during a
podcast while I'm like,
well,
that definitely wasn't me.
Yeah,
no,
definitely.
They get you with like $10 ones,
like little $3 $10 to test the waters and just start quad microphones accurately
pick up sound from four meters away with a wall.
Wait,
what is that real spine on your brother?
Yeah,
Dude.
What doing,
what they're not telling you is the microphones are always active.
Always.
Yeah.
Just like your phone.
They're always listening.
The government bro Translate Multiple Epp people.
Oh,
great.
Microsoft translator.
You hear about the new TVs,
you hear about the uh,
the LG,
the LG TVs that was spying on people constantly listening.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
And they told you if you want to have a private confidential conversation,
don't have it in front of the TV.
What they were basically saying,
what did you bring your wife in front of the TV?
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Does that have cameras on them?
They have camera.
Yeah.
I think it live streams at t I think it's like a sex mode.